this life is not an easy one  I've made enemies powerful enemies put  those I love in danger but the one thing  that is haunting me my entire life is  finding the truth about my parents  you're a wanted man Peter Parker don't  believe what the police are saying to  you  my dad has 500 officers looking for you  500 seems a bit excessive  you know if you're gonna steal cars  don't dress like a car thief you found  my weakness it's small knives  goodbye  tell us a little bit about yourself mr.  Parker  what does your father do Peter find  everybody knew my father my parents left  I was very out you don't know something  you understand did you tell the boy  about his father dr. Connors mr.  Parker's son if you want the truth about  your parents Peter come and get it  ready to play God there's been a  biological attacks law to York City  secrets have a cost  I can't stop him  do you think what happened to you Peter  it was an accident  any idea  but you really are